this is stupid but on my phone this guy
you'll laugh at this maybe a lot of
people get these pictures or tattoos you
know like of me as joe dirt you know
they said you a lot of you get a lot of
tattoos of stuff like things you say or
photos or whatever they send me one's a
farley or whatever so this this guy says
we want to he's got norm of all morons
on his hand nor mcdonald
so i text norm i go i just send it to
him i go hey you have fans and then i
put princess fan
oh all we know is for sure this one guy
and then um and then of course like
days later david hello it's me norm
how are you
have you ever texted with norm it's no i
haven't no times a thousand he just goes
he waits days and then at three in the
morning hello
i go norm
what are you are you answering me from
four days ago is that what you're doing
dave it's norm
you like money
yes norm i like money why
would you like to have more money than
all your wildest dreams
yes i would
and then an hour later would you like to
walk into a dealership and point to a
car and then just buy it i go of course
i how and then three hours later bet the
over in the blackhawks game
first period or something
you know what's funny is that that
reminds me i was just thinking about
this the other day norm
was on my late night show and always an
amazing uh guest and some of my favorite
moments and he's in the makeup room
getting made up and you know the band's
playing we're about i'm about to go out
and start the show
but i go in just to say hey
to norman what i want to do is make sure
i like to get in sync with people a
little beforehand just make sure that
you know we're both yeah on the same
page get a good groove going so i go in
the band's plan and norm's always great
like hey norm good to see you he's like
ah
hey yeah yeah can you back out of the
way i'm trying to see the the television
set can you back back up there conan and
uh tv the tv's on and so i i sort of
back out of the way and i realize he's
watching some college basketball game
and he's watching it it's towards the
end of the game and all this and i go
like okay well anyway good lady guys can
you be quiet yeah quiet
and then someone scores a basket and he
goes and it's the game's over and he
goes like ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i'm like what anyone i just
lost
just lost a lot of money
and my whole dirty work yeah guys
everything i made on on dirty work is
gone
and and i just went oh and he went oh
i'm in a terrible mood and i went okay
and then someone with a headset
said conan it's time to go on and i went
i'll see you out there and he's like
you
you came in and jinxed me you chased me
i'm gonna [ __ ] up your show oh i'm doing
a show with the jinx
i'm gonna jinx my set